just when we feel like everything's
under control it's out of control again
news this morning while we are on the
air of patriots cornerback staphon
gilmore the defending nfl defensive
player of the year
testing positive
for coven 19 won't practice today the
team will not practice today because the
team now has
three
cam newton
bill murray practice squad defensive
tackle and stefan gilmore murray was not
in contact with cam newton at least not
in close contact with cam newton gilmore
i don't know whether or not he was on
the plane with the 20 right who had been
in close contact with cam newton or
whether he was on the plane with
everyone else
it's it's probably better for the
patriots if he was on the plane with the
20 because again there's a lag between
when you shed virus and when they find
out you're positive the numbers they're
getting now wednesday morning are the
result of pcr tests that were
implemented tuesday morning so when he
was tested tuesday morning
after they got back from kansas city
he tested positive not good which means
which means he may have been shedding
virus on the plane right he may have
been shedding virus on the field if he
went up and said hello to patrick
mahomes after the game he may have shed
virus on him look this gets back to
everything we talked about an hour ago
and i've already gotten emails from
people why are you talking about this
this is why we're talking about it folks
because it continues to threaten
to
force the nfl to work magic on its
schedule and if it can't do that
to either have two extra weeks at the
back end of the season or miss games or
worst case scenario shut down the season
now it's not going to come to that what
it needs to come to chris i'm going to
keep banging this drone and you need to
join with me i am
you know that big ass bass drum in the
band right we each get get a get uh what
is it called you know the big club and
we just hit it on each side put every
team
in a hotel national football league
players association i'm begging you
forget about collective bargaining i
know that that is the core of what you
do and you never agree to anything
without getting something in return
sometimes though it's about doing the
right thing for everyone and if you want
your players to get their game checks
this year you will tell every player
you're going to a hotel and you're
staying there for the rest of the season
it's a sacrifice but you're going to
sacrifice a lot of money you're going to
sacrifice some games you're going to
undermine the season and the sooner the
union agrees to it because the league
will do it coaches are going to be upset
about it so what too bad you're getting
paid a lot of money go live in a hotel
for three months they need to do it or
the season i'm not gonna say it's gonna
implode but we're gonna have a team
that's nine and six or nine and five get
to the playoffs yeah and a team that's
nine and seven say what the hell is
going on here and it's not gonna feel
fair to anyone it's not gonna be a
complete season no that's the way to
save it chris you're right i mean i'm
mike you're a hundred percent i mean you
said it last week you know i had for a
moment hesitated but you're right i mean
if we want to ensure that there's less
questions
about the fairness let's say or the
competitive imbalance and all of those
type of things and then also capitalize
just hey for the nfl to capitalize on
all the money they can possibly make and
do all those things
it is uh it's to me the only way that's
gonna make it right now the way it's
looking and i mean with stefan gilmore
man holy cow you lose your best player
on offense last week now it's gonna be
your best player on defense this week
and
i just
where does this go the patriots play
like bump and run man to man in your
face like every play i mean what tyree
kill at sammy watkins right now must be
going man stefan gilmore was like
someplace on me like glue on monday
night i mean he he probably could they
could probably smell the bubble gum
flavor he was chewing that's how close
they were to each other at times so
that's just got to be scary and that's
to me where like
where does this go now because
you know again like we saw last week it
there's a delayed reaction in the spread
of this virus obviously where yeah one
guy gets it and just slowly trickles to
the next guy at times to can you feel
safe that
okay the chief's tested everyone's good
today that they won't get it or won't
have someone else get it here in the
next three days that's where uh the
virus is scary to me right now and that
that look it's that trickle it's that
drip it's that day after day after day
we're seeing it in the white house
we're seeing it now with the patriots
and oh by the way espn reports
that and we talked about this last hour
mike vrabel coach of the titans waiting
for his 4 30 a.m email are there more
positives oops
there's another positive in tennessee
you know what that means they're not
going back to work today you know what
that means you know what that means your
boy blue got another probably not going
probably not going to tennessee this
weekend and what are they going to do
what are they going to do you're right
what are they gonna wha what what what
do we do now are we at the point after
four weeks of the season where they have
to park a week 18 delay wild card
weekend by a week delay the divisional
weekend by a week delay the conference
championship by a week and either delay
the super bowl by a week or just have a
one week lag between the conference
championships and the super bowl that's
where we are because there's there's
nowhere else this game can go the titans
have already had their buy
you can't put it anywhere except week
18. unless you postpone it to monday or
tuesday but what happened with the
patriots
in postpo i mean we don't again one of
the keys is was stefan gilmore one of
the people in close contact with cam
newton if yes then it just underscores
the fact that they they just shouldn't
have played that game they knew there
was a risk and it's the incubation
period we've talked about this over and
over again that is the doughnut hole
here that is the thing that causes the
titan's positives to keep coming and
coming more than a week after they have
shut down their facility guys are
testing positive so
uh
it is time
to put
the
players the coaches
and all personnel in hotels for the rest
of the season or
there is not going to be a rest of the
season at least as it relates to getting
all the games in chris yeah well because
we just we just don't know you know we
don't know you know we've obviously seen
we can't totally trust the players as of
right now we've seen
you know coaches be relaxed about it as
well
you know i sit there and think about the
titans too and go
okay you know is this something that's
trickling through the team because of
the spread through the team
or is it also like hey we're not at the
facility and i went to some restaurant
with my wife and kids you know
uh the second day we didn't have
practice last week and i got it there
you know so that's where it's that's
where like your point about the hotel
and the bubble and everything there too
is
it's just there's so many variables in
this there there really is
and unless you basically lock yourself
down i just don't know how we avoid it
going forward unless
unless and like you said it's going to
be unfair
unless we start to see this become a
real thing and then the nfl again goes
back to what we kind of saw in that
statement from goodell and everything
the other day where
maybe he starts to threaten and go
you know i don't know you guys can't be
trusted team x
there seems to be an outbreak every week
somebody you know we we've lost wiggle
room in the in the schedule
it's just time you get a loss you can't
play this week you get a loss we're
moving on with the nfl season you know i
mean it to me it's got to be it's going
to have to be one of the other at some
point it is i just i don't know how you
make it fair
and uh to me that's still the fairest
way to go instead of having imbalance in
the number of games like i would be so
pissed off of an nfl football player if
the scenario you said uh or like you
know a rose of
i'm on a and seven team
and
i don't get in the playoffs because some
team that went nine and five
and avoided the steelers and the bills
to get in
the like two of the best teams in
football i mean that that is
like the bs's of the bs's right there
that's bull crap and uh that that really
bothers me as you can tell it kind of
boils my blood a little bit
i've had i've had a couple of coaches
suggest a 12-game season
um
with or without a bubble i i think the
coaches really don't want to have to
live in hotels no they don't think about
it most of the coaches have pretty nice
houses right they don't want to be away
from their families i get it yep but you
know what the entire nba went to orlando
the nhl went to two different cities in
canada and then they had one giant
bubble and look i i said back in march
half jokingly that's what the nfl needs
to do
get get a huge
piece of land in area 51 and start
building dormitories and fields on which
games would be played but the only way
this is going to work is to keep guys in
the building once you know everyone
is negative now you don't want to keep
all the titans in the building for now
or in the hotel for now you don't want
to keep all the patriots in the building
for now or in the hotel for now but once
you know everyone's clean and you have
that runway of allowing the incubation
period to evaporate
then you lock everyone down in hotels
and and you know what if they do have to
just pull the plug on the season for a
couple of weeks to get this reconfigured
and start it up again and move things
back so be it i understand what's that
dude so we can move it let me finish let
me finish can i finish
if if you
the problem is
once you delay it beyond the end of
february you start screwing up the
entire offseason schedule when do you do
free agency when do you do the draft
when do you start preparing for the next
season how much time is there between
seasons from a health and safety
standpoint you don't want because look
at look at what basketball and hockey
you're going to have to do what would do
now hey
hey we finished our seasons we've
awarded a championship now when the hell
do we start again i don't think the nfl
wants to do that it can become a
perpetual mess for all these sports
they're going to do it the same way
they're doing it that's the dumbest
thing i've ever heard i mean oh let's
delay it so we can do the same formula
and then have seven more delays as we do
that and we'll play the super bowl in uh
july we'll do it on july 4th i mean well
we can't predict where this is going to
be as a in our country and the virus in
the world everything down so at some
point it's either got to come to the
bubble idea like you're saying 32
individual bubbles or we just say you
lose we move on that's a i mean i i hear
the delay thing the delay thing yes
makes sense but what is that like you
said it doesn't ensure there's not going
to be more delays and then what are we
going to do have the super bowl in may
and then delay the next season because
of that so at some point we just got to
crap or get off the pot here and figure
something out that either works or we
just keep moving the train and go along
and hope sorry you get a loss
that at least would make sense to me
and and here's the thing all right
you get a loss right if that's what they
say to the titans this week you get a
loss
bills win you're three and one they're
five and oh
they gotta they gotta write a huge check
back to cbs
right i don't think cbs is gonna say
fine go ahead keep the money i
understand that all the networks are
currently in negotiations with the nfl
but there's a limit to which the the
networks are going to say
oh you're not giving us content and
we're paying for it oh we're fine with
that
we want to continue to give you billions
of dollars so we're fine with not having
programming uh because you guys couldn't
get your crap together we're fine with
that
let's assume that that money gets paid
back here's the thing if you how what do
you do how do you pay the players if the
game's forfeited what do you do do you
tell the players you
hey bills you didn't get to play the
game this week because the titans have
an outbreak and they haven't been able
to get it under control you get a win
congratulations yeah but you know we got
some other news for you you're not
getting a check this week because the
only way we can justify paying you
because we can't have fans come to the
game
is we need our money from cbs right hope
you understand it yeah i hope you
understand and hope you saved some of
your money because you ain't getting
paid this make the titans
make the titans pay the bills payroll
for the week
to pay their own pay the bills
but that's why chris that's why the
bubble is the only way out yeah that's
why putting the players in a hotel and
telling them you can't leave and this is
it and give them another window to opt
out if they don't want to do it fine
yeah you get it you get your stipend you
go go you don't want to be here go we
want we'll find people who want to be
here we'll we'll seal the doors we go
from hotel to practice facility to hotel
to practice facility we go to the
stadium we go to the airport very
restricted universe of movement we're
keeping out anyone that may be positive
that's what they got to do yeah now
they could have planned it this way from
the start or they could do it on the fly
see to their pants make it up as they go
which introduces the possibility of some
flaws and some problems but uh it's what
they need to do and the sooner they do
it the better and you know just as it
felt like the dust was settling
the dust has kicked up again and this is
going to continue and the biggest
problem here is when the hell are the
bills and titans going to play when are
they going to play yeah because it's
probably not going to be sunday and
monday or tuesday may not make a
difference and there's no bye week that
you can drop this into because the
titans buy has already disappeared
that's and to everyone out there let me
just make this one last point
to everyone out there
who says
it's not going to kill any of these
players
the survival rate for people under 70 is
whatever percent you want to quote
whatever you heard on on on tv that you
want to quote fine
none of that matters what matters is the
nfl has made this the tactical decision
that this is the way they're going to do
things that if you're positive you don't
come to work
and if there are enough positives
they're going to shut down a facility
they're not they're not looking at it in
terms of is it going to make somebody
sick or is it going to kill them they
don't want the virus to run rampant they
don't want to try to do the swedish herd
immunity experiment with the national
football league they've made that
decision they're not doing it so none of
your statistics about who it kills and
who it doesn't kill none of those matter
the nfl's already made the decision this
is how they're going to do things so the
recommendations we are making come from
the perspective
of getting the games played within the
confines of the decisions the nfl's
already made chris so you know this
isn't fear-mongering this isn't about
what the virus can do to anyone this is
about what the nfl needs to do to
successfully play its games given the
choices it's already made about how it's
going to handle the virus yeah yeah no
uh i mean
yeah we're not trying to fear monger at
all i don't i don't even you know i
don't get that we're trying to lay out
with what the nfl is trying to set up
where this is going and how it might go
and maybe throw some ideas out there to
help it along um
you know you mentioned the players and
the coaches reluctant about the bubble
and all those things i think at the end
of the day they will do it i do i mean
of course there's just too much money to
be lost even for low-level guys who are
making the minimum you know they have
made no money so yeah and i know my my
wife we've talked about this too hey
honey if i was a starting quarterback
and making 25 million dollars a year she
should be i'll see you go to the bubble
i'll see you when the season's over you
know or she'd ask can we go to the
bubble with you and yeah you know maybe
maybe that's an option you know maybe
some kids miss grade school or just do
it online anyways because a lot of them
are doing that anyway so maybe they
could set something up like that but the
other thing here
after that
you know for the like hang on a second i
got some news i got some news okay uh
stefan gilmore was one of the players in
close contact with cam newton so he
would have been on the plane with
roughly 20 people back and forth to
kansas city which is
both good news and bad news it's bad
news really well but but here's where
it's good news yeah he wasn't on the
plane with everybody else right which
which is a little shred of good news but
it just it demonstrates the incubation
period it demonstrates that that this is
the thing the nfl is never going to be
able to address no matter what it does
it's going to be a drip drip drip
potentially
of positive tests once you have that one
guy who's positive especially a guy who
interacts with so many people like the
starting quarterback yeah and uh
that that is the the very bad news here
and it's bad news for the patriots and
it's bad news for the league because it
just shows how hard it's going to be to
get this season in
if your approach is
we got to shut it down if someone's
positive we can't let the person in and
if we start having a chain of these
positives we're going to assume there's
an outbreak and we're going to slam the
door on the facility and we're going to
start postponing or canceling football
games chris there those i mean
yeah he was on a plane with 20 guys on a
separate plane he still played in a
football field with 50 other people i
mean and he was tackling and probably
drooled on people and was on top of
people and like you said hey wait wait
where did you see the photo we had well
let's see let's see yeah well well
they're trying
good news good news chiefs fans oh
there's stephon gilmore right patrick
holmes face after the game yeah that
makes you question
why was that game played but then it's
also gonna be like it's gonna be a huge
experiment here going forward just to
see
okay as it relates to like the titans
bills game this week just you know how
how does this play out
no do we continue to see the spread now
with more and more patriot players and
chief players because of this i i don't
know um but you know it's a yes scary
time here to see where this goes this
week for those football teams right now
and and to see if they can possibly play
or make this happen i don't know
yeah uh
it it really is amazing
that you know last tuesday one of the
things i stupidly said hey
they've cracked the code on covet three
weeks and everything's fine and if
someone told me over the weekend it's
like an average golfer getting a par on
the first three holes of the course the
triple bogey is always coming the triple
bogey came last week and now
just when it looked like you know you're
feeling confidence that par three and
you've you've parted in the past and you
know you can put the the ball on the
green with one shot and two putt you're
fine you put it in the water you put it
in the weeds you put it in the woods you
put it in the sand that's where they are
already just when it felt like
everything was moving in the right
direction oh by the way there's another
raiders player who's tested positive as
well so titans
patriots raiders all three teams now
in this mess and the nfl's got to figure
it out on the fly
and and again the the only solution the
best solution
put
every team in a hotel
and restrict their movements for the
rest of the season that's how you get
the season in and if you don't want to
do that if the union doesn't want to do
it fine what do we have some teams are
going to play 10 games some are going to
play 12 some are going to play nine
someone will be it's going to be
non-stop and and eventually what's going
to happen chris fans are just going to
say screw it why am i messing with it
i don't know where the hell the game is
going to be what's the game going to be
on yeah is there a game monday night or
isn't there a game monday night is my
favorite team playing or isn't it how in
the hell do i keep up with fantasy
football right i mean there are a lot
there are millions of people who derive
their primary enjoyment of following the
nfl from playing fantasy football
last week
wreaked havoc on fantasy football
rosters if they start missing games and
week 18 and week 19 and canceling
whatever
this can't continue and their only
chance is to put everyone in a bubble
yeah i mean i'm i'm with you i just um
i you know the thing that comes to my
mind here is just you know going forward
you know will the nfl even take the
chance of
oh
this all right just like the new england
scenario
you know okay cam newton's tested
positive here's 20 people that were
close to him
you know
at what point does the nfl just go we
can't even risk it anymore i'm sorry 20
people you're gone for now
or or whatever that is i i don't know
but you know obviously we're seeing here
that there's great risk and we're gonna
see what happens here this week as we go
on
because a guy that was now positive
played in a football game was on a
separate plane because you knew he had
contact with a guy that was also
positive
and now where does it go you know this
is going to be
a great test you know and just to see
where this is all out how quickly it
does spread and maybe what they do going
forward but yeah the bubble mic back to
that is just that it's the only way it's
going to get done here smoothly i agree
with you
can we put that photo back up again
of patrick holmes and stefan gilmore
this is the
the test
right the nfl has banked on the idea
that in an open-air setting
you're not going to transmit the virus
that that the droplets dissipate too
quickly i mean that's as close as two
football players can get yeah my guess
is they're not holding their breath
during that conversation
and uh this probably has to be canceled
too mike like these things like no more
doing this after the game no more like i
don't know why there's i thought they
weren't supposed to do it remember the
whole thing no jersey swaps yeah well
why
why don't they just do what vic fangio
did and to get your ass straight to the
locker room
right that's what should ha and why
i mean
look
it doesn't take a genius to figure this
out if you and i can figure it out that
proves it
get why do you want to and see the other
side of it is they were just out there
pressed up against each other for three
hours see that's the problem the more
that we do to keep everyone separated
and all the measures that are put in
place you must wear a mask you must stay
six feet apart you must do this you must
do that at some point you're playing
football and it's harder to reconcile
playing football with everything else
you're doing to prevent transmission of
the virus so that's why the football
players justified hey we've been out
here for the last three hours playing
football we're fine we get tested every
day yes we're fine right well guess what
the morning after that photo was taken
stefan gilmore had a swab go up his nose
that came back positive
and
that means there's a chance he was
shedding virus
in that moment in that photo
and and now if you're a chiefs fan if
you're a fan of football if you just if
you want the best players on the field
and we all love patrick mahomes we don't
want to see his back up
uh there's a chance that at some point
over the next week 10 days two weeks
however long the incubation period
patrick holmes is going to test positive
there's a chance that's going to happen
now maybe that's what needs to happen to
make the bubble thing happen maybe it is
maybe we just got the best player in the
sports gotta whoa mahomes can't play the
team that won the super bowl the best
player in our league the face of the
league right now he can't play you know
that that that would be i think a major
like shot across the bow to everybody
the society everything to just be like
all right anybody can get this and it
can mess up our you know daily life or
routine at any point and certainly it
would put the nfl and everything on
notice when you lose a guy of the
caliber of the patrick mahomes
and let me just say this i i don't know
whether it's bots on twitter
or i don't know a lot of bots people
people are so
effing stupid
seven months into this they don't
understand it i had one person say oh
don't worry about my homes they all
tested negative yesterday don't you
understand folks there's an incubation
period that's how this works you don't
test positive the morning after someone
breathes virus into your face it takes
time for enough virus to accumulate in
your body to show up on the test and it
accumulates in your nose that's why they
stick the swab up your nose that so it
takes time yeah
it is amazing to me
how deliberately misinformed so many
americans are about this virus that has
killed 210 000 people and counting how
can we be so so willfully stupid and
willfully and blissfully ignorant about
something this serious it is astounding
to me and i've got my theories as to why
it happened regardless it's happened and
now we're seeing it play out for the
national football league and and we're
we're at the point where
we we just have to wait and see what
happened somebody told me over the
weekend that they're not going to do the
bubble but if there's one more incident
they'll do the bubble we'll just see if
this feels this kind of feels like the
incident chris doesn't it if they're
ever going to do the bubble they need to
do it now
it seems like it you know it does i mean
it's
you know gilmore the patriots it's like
whoa if the patriots are having an issue
i can guarantee the patriots are doing
just about everything right that's just
the way they work it is
i mean if that's a rule i just would be
you know they're gonna follow protocol
pretty strictly so that that that hits
home to me and then yes you know
tennessee's scary again yeah another con
you know the test there where does it go
with the raiders we know they were
careless last week too what does that
mean i mean there's just so many
question marks and to your point with
like you know your email you got with
people saying oh don't worry about my
homes he tested negative yesterday well
yeah i'm sure the guy that tested
positive for the titans today tested
negative for the last six days in a row
but today it's positive so again yeah
that's just the way it is to your point
it's it has to take time to spread
through the body so it's only news when
they're positive right right right
stephon gilmore wasn't tested for the
first time this week on tuesday he was
negative on saturday on sunday and on
monday but the incubation period he was
one of the guys as we mentioned earlier
who was in close contact with
uh
cam newton right
the incubation period expires and he's
has positive so that's kind of where we
are and it's not it's not uh
not good no um it's not good not good at
all
uh hopefully we have football to
continue to talk about in the coming
days and weeks hopefully they will get
this together and get this fixed that's
what we want and that's the other thing
too you know um
i it
it
and again it may be bots it's bots it's
trolls and it's idiots the idea that by
merely talking about this by making
suggestions aimed at saving the season
we want the season to fail don't you
realize the lack of logic there if we
really wanted the season to fail
we'd be arguing ah don't do anything ah
it's phony uh it's not nobody's gonna
get sick you don't need to do anything
it's fine you're no
we want to save the season that's why
we're sounding the alarm we want the
games to happen we want the players to
get paid we want to have sports that we
can enjoy on the weekends to give us a
temporary break from all the crap that
we got to deal with the other six days
of the week
and we're we're making arguments
aimed at allowing it to happen
that's why we want the bubble we want
all the teams to be in a bubble so they
can play the games and yes that's
selfish from our standpoint i know it's
a hardship for the players and the
coaches but
we want the games to be played yeah
presumably they want the games to be
played and we've been at a point for a
while now where that's the only obvious
solution and i just wish that people who
are actually in a position chris of
power and influence in the nfl other
than us unlike us will do something
about it and make that decision yeah
either we're getting there mike i you
know i think the statement that good
goodell you know
you know uh released last week and
everything there
it shows you their mind is there
and you know to to what you said just a
few minutes ago
this might be the the last straw or
whatever whatever you want to say there
to where they just go okay you know it's
getting out of hand i'm not sure we can
control this we got to do something we
got to go to plan b and i would expect
we start to hear more and more of that
as this week goes on
well i thought we'd hear it over the
weekend and we didn't and if we don't
hear it over the next few days
look here's the thing they're going to
realize that's the only option because
the next move is week 18. you're not
going to be able to reschedule this
bill's titans game this bill's titans
game is going to get played wild card
weekend if at all i doubt it's going to
get played on monday night or tuesday
night and uh that's just the way it is
yeah that
you you you once you use the titans buy
for last week you have no other
flexibility you have no other leeway and
and look
hey do what you have to do to salvage
the season if you need to start pushing
things back do it but don't just do that
get everyone into a hotel
mandatory
give guys a chance to opt out players
coaches and everyone else anyone who
wants to say i'm out i can't do this i
can't be away from my family i don't
want to be away from my family i don't
want to live in a hotel for three months
give them the chance to do it that's
fair and that's proper you don't want
anyone in there who doesn't want to be
in there like mike tomlin always says we
want volunteers we want people who want
to be yeah doesn't want people who don't
right yeah yeah we don't want hostages
we want volunteers and i understand that
for some people the prospect of not
getting their salary operates is the
golden handcuffs that will cause them to
do it but still they're choosing to do
it they're making that choice it's not
going to be mandatory for anybody
there's not going to be any penalty
under the collective bargaining
agreement for leaving the team without
permission
everyone should have a chance to say i
choose not to do this
everyone who chooses to do it should be
all in for the rest of the year and
let's get the games in and i'll admit
i'm being selfish i want the games to be
played chris i assume you feel the same
way you want the games to be played if
they don't do something drastic now
we're not going to have the games played
i would be crushed i i i it's part of my
livelihood yeah like to support my
family but it's like truly part of my
being this time of the year i want to
watch football and
just
it's it's yeah i love it so of course i
want to see it and that's why we're
arguing about let's do things safer or
do the bubble or things like that
because we want to see football you know
what make no sense for the people that
are arguing that we're fear-mongering or
doing anything like that that's crazy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports